des x hello all right welcome everybody
we've got a whole bunch of people
watching in the chat why don't you
quickly introduce yourself to us we are
live and then we can get into your
questions right hello everybody my name
is Nate eleuthera and i'm calling from
Auckland New Zealand today it's a cold
morning as looking at quarter past eight
sorry for the delay earlier we've got
some trouble with the Wi-Fi connection
here so I've got that reasonably fixed i
believe so hopefully we won't get
disconnected but it's a pleasure to be
here that's pleasure to be speaking to
the great Evan Carmichael and really
looking forward to this chat cool man
well just quick intro to what the
founder chat concept is all about just
from my my viewers to come on you're
saying and then and then your you know
whatever questions you have fire away
and let's do it oh it's fantastic so
everybody i actually have launched firm
academy which you can check out online
WWF urm quetta me and within that run an
online series a video-based series
called founder chats and done some
amazing interviews with some some
like-minded entrepreneurs and founders
with some really cool success stories to
inspire as other aspiring entrepreneurs
and founders out there including myself
I always get inspired by these chats and
so again this chat which I'm glued with
evan is the first live chat I've
actually ever done so I hope it goes
well but i'm really looking for two
again some really good quality learnings
which is the key takeaway that we like
to achieve from a founders chat session
so that we can we can learn and grow
from our experiences what time is it in
New Zeeland right now oh so it's 815 am
in your future so the next morning okay
that's not that bad it looks dark and
yeah I feeling like like it's four in
the morning or something and you are
soon on and okay that's not that bad ATM
is not that bad okay let's get into like
yeah let's do it what's your what's your
first question yeah sure look
let's start with you know even I've been
following your stuff for for a few years
actually and really love the emails that
come through and the stories that you
share the videos about other inspiring
entrepreneurs so you know put together
some really good quality questions but
let's I'd love to just start with your
view on community building the concept
of community building today's generation
because really is it's almost like it's
one hundred percent online nowadays so
that's YouTube community building or
social media community building and just
being able to do that from scratch you
know and working up the courage to do
that and also some strategies on how you
can do that effectively because it can
get frustrating sometimes when you don't
see traction yeah I think so cuz it's a
lot there I think first you have to care
like community building has to be
something that's in you but you have to
you have to want to meet people and to
help make their lives better and bring
people together think it's a fantastic
marketing strategy but if you don't
actually care about people that much you
know then then it's not going to work
for you there's so many different
strategies that you can do but then
community bill is one of them but again
you have to love the process like just
because I may come on and say community
building is the way of the future and
that's how you got to market yourself it
doesn't mean that that's going to work
for you you got to find the thing that
fits your personality so for me I love
my community right I love my YouTube
community especially I'm in the comments
every day I want everybody to get a
response most of it is that I make are
about um request that people put in to
my channel you know i like that it feeds
me i wake up every morning and look at
the comments and that gives me energy to
want to do more and be better i think it
doesn't only have to be online I look at
my my business my salsa business trying
to dance salsa in one we started a
meetup group around that so yes to
connect initially online but then the
whole point is that they get together in
an offline setting
people come to our school to learn to
dance but also to really to meet people
because they're they're isolated and
lonely and they're just stuck in their
phones and so it's a way of really
bringing people together so to get
started one like actually care and and
then to don't be so focused about I need
to get you know a thousand more people
on my thing it's really about making an
impact on the people who do come you
don't even impact on one person that
person going to come back they're gonna
tell their friends their friends are
going to come and it's caring about them
all of the process you to help them get
to you know whatever whatever the goal
is of your business for me to help
believe in yourself Creek companies for
other people might be how to learn
guitar or learn the dancer you know
become an author or whatever it is
people are so attached like the angle
without enjoying the process along the
way so really focusing on quality over
quantity and then quantities like the
byproduct of that in a way but carrying
along the way yes the quality quantity
thing is interesting because the real
answer is is actually both right like
yes you need quality quality is what
gets you if you just bump it out like if
i make my youtube channel i'm pumping
out a thousand crappy videos a day
doesn't matter how much quantity i put
out you're gonna help but if i'm only
doing one video a year that's probably
not going to be good either unless it's
like just insanely epic what people
you'll kind of feel understanding is the
quantity leads to the quality for me to
give you quality i need practice like my
channel has become good because I've
done 3500 videos that's a lot of
quantity and not all the moving have
been published so if you want to be able
to provide quality to your customers to
your community then you need a lot of
practice whether it's in your own
community you're going to other
communities so at the start you're going
to suck just like anything else and you
slowly get better and so the you need
both quality and quantity and the
quality helps you I sorry the quality
helps you lead to the quantity the
quality I'm not all the placer the
quantity
you need the quality I mean and then you
know in saying that you know like i said
i've been watching your stuff for a few
years but one thing I've noticed with
you is that you stayed consistent in a
lot of your content so the stuff that I
could I could go back and read some of
your content from you know couple years
back but it would still be very much
aligned to the stuff they be releasing
today you know it's about
entrepreneurship it's about inspiration
it's about success stories of other
entrepreneurs and I think one of the
challenges is everybody talks about
staying consistent in authentic and when
you are releasing content but how can
you also to show you to stay relevant
because if you stay consistent authentic
for today's generation and you're doing
that over a period of five ten years do
you just expect your audience to grow
with you how how would you then tap into
the next generation and still be
relevant to that I stay relevant to the
audience into the market by staying
relevant to myself I am my market I make
stuff that I love and thankfully a lot
of people love it as well I don't put
out content like I don't put out content
trying to attract the 16 year old new
entrepreneur who was all over snapchat
although like in looking at the people
watching live we've got 14 and 15 16
year olds watching I put out content
that i love that are that is for me that
makes me [ __ ] a lot that i wish i had
when i was starting my business and
that's still today give me value for
what i'm doing i think if you are just
trying to i think so many companies do
that i think so many companies look at
oh this is new market developing how to
been going to attract those where you
have maybe you have no interest like you
know maybe you don't have any business
attracting those guys you know maybe the
content you're going to make is going to
be crack because you're just trying to
appeal to a 14 year old and it doesn't
resonate with you at all where I think
you've got to create stuff that makes
you come alive and for me you talk about
the consistency and stain on message I
really worried about like message in
staying consistent like oh is this the
same thing that I said two years ago or
two months ago really it's about just
being authentic and when you're when you
are when you when you tell the truth you
don't to worry about all the lies that
you've told I try to go straight in your
head and so I think it's important to
find out what it is that you staying for
for me it's about finding the one word
that defines who you are and that's a
topic of my nonstick hold on yes I have
that's the top of my new book that's
coming out to be careful I just
announced it um and so then when you
understand the value of what you staying
for then the lens through which I see
the world is believed and the way I'm
able to help it make an impact is
through entrepreneurship because that's
what I have an understanding of and so I
helped believe in entrepreneurs and so
all my content has been around that
consistently the actual videos may have
changed like the top 10 series that
people no one loved and talked about in
the chat you know I didn't have those
two years ago the in special series I
didn't have those two years ago it was
more just answering questions from the
audience but the message has
consistently been the same I may have
more energy now I mean turn up a little
bit more than I did before because the
quantity leads to better quality most of
the opinions that I have are the same or
consistent there may be some things that
you know I may have changed my approach
on something but I think as long as
you're being true to yourself and
growing your business as you grow as a
human being too many people get trapped
into well this is what worked for me two
years ago and so I'm just going to keep
doing it even though i don't really like
it anymore like i'm kind of bored of
doing that but it's what's working and
bringing me money so i'm just going to
keep doing that and not growing and
expanding and the trick is as you grow
and change the human being you need to
incorporate that into your business
otherwise it'll start it a little flat
line and then go down because you don't
have the same energy and passion at your
point into it so i think as long as
you're creating something that you love
and makes you come alive other people
will too
it's interesting you know you raise the
passion and purpose and in today's
millennial generation I'd say you know
they're all about passion and purpose
and in what they do I'd love to hear
your thoughts on millennial
entrepreneurship versus because I know a
lot of the videos you've made is you
know we're talking about the earlier
entrepreneurs like the Steve Jobs of the
world of what Disney's of the world you
know the guys who I would call
traditional entrepreneurs from an era
before the digital age and in today's
digital age almost anyone can pick up
their laptop with internet and become an
entrepreneur so how do you see the game
exchange the Entrepreneurship game has
changed you know in that journey I think
it's just become easier I think that the
the cost of entry is so low to get in
you don't have to buy a building in hire
a team and manufacturer you know picture
frames or ginger snap or whatever right
like you don't need to have those
facilities you can just start from a
laptop so that the cost to get started
are way lower and there's there's a lot
of people to look up to now this there's
young entrepreneurs who have made it and
had success and so there's role models
to look to you know being the one of the
first young entrepreneurs might be scary
being the first black entrepreneur be
scary being the first woman entrepreneur
might be scary but now there's so many
role models to look up to say oh well he
did it she did it I can do it too so
those two things combined I think people
always wanted to do their passion uh you
look at kids I have a son you don't you
have kids yet I have a son just turned
seven you know he wants to do what he
wants to do like we are born this way we
want to do the things that we want to do
one that we love and then as we get
older and as we get safe and as we get
jobs that gets kind of beaten out of us
and we just end up you know working for
the man and bowling orders and living
for the evenings a weekend so I don't
know that I don't think that today's
millennial generation is any different
than the other generations growing up
the difference in terms of like their
their passion and wanting to do
something for themselves I think it's
just more that's weight easier to do it
now
more opportunities to do it now than
we've ever had and there's more role
models look to to know that it's
possible so um in saying that you know
we also hear a lot about the young guys
and the disruption and the tech
disruption going on and just being able
to you know do things differently and
outside the status quo and all that what
are your thoughts on entrepreneurship by
that style or are you more in you know
are you more into sort of when you doing
entrepreneurship you should try and make
the world a better place because i think
is kind of two different dynamics so you
try to make the world a better place or
you're disrupting a current status quo
current form yeah you know i would put
those together i I disrupt you know I
make the world a better place by
disrupting the status quo once that okay
and then but when you when you're doing
that you know some like you look at the
tech disruption that's going on I think
what we get here on the side of the ones
we get kind of to two sides of it I'm
totally for the disruption of the tech
disruption that's going on as well I
think it's fantastic but I think there's
also a little bit of pushback in terms
of resistance to change to actually
accepting it as well so like you know is
that a generational mindset mindset
thing or what is what would you so not
so it's all this is human nature we
don't like change right don't like
change you know when when the car came
out the guys with the horse and buggies
were pissed like technology disrupts and
if you're losing business and you don't
want to innovate and change if you're
not leading that revolution then you're
going to get upset and you're going to
fight it you know I don't know what it's
like a New Zealand but recently in
toronto all the taxi guys were upset
about uber coming in and kind of
disrupting their business like uber is
the future it can be in me as a future
you got to be able to keep up with that
and there was always going to be people
who is it's not just this generation
it's happened forever ah you know so
it's something you did that back in the
day I was reading you also introduced
software and and took that from from
sort of you know it from the college
days up to an exit as well yeah
what was that journey like was that
quite a but a tough journey to go
through you know some advice to other
entrepreneurs trying to get into the
let's say software-as-a-service uh it
will that really sucked hard uh and then
was amazing oh we oh we know among the
worst days of my life and part of that
business I had opportunities to work at
big companies and make lots of money and
turned it down to do this job the this
company that was an owner and that I
didn't know if I was going to work out
and I thought might have been the worst
decision of my life in terms of
translating that to kind of advice for
entrepreneurs for me the the thing that
I learned the most from that is I don't
want to live with regret right that if
there's something that I'm scared of
doing or something that I'm on the fence
of or something that might be pushing
aluminum personal belief of mine I don't
want to just default to the safe path
because it's a safe path and everybody
says to go and do it even if my friends
and family are you know questioning me
or people online you know think you're
crazy I try to look at my life when I'm
90 years old or maybe by the time I get
there I'll be like 150 years old because
we can live and looking back like I
don't want to look back on this day and
in regret that I was too afraid to make
the right decision and that helps me
bust through the fear and so I almost
didn't go with my company we weren't
doing well it's making 300 girls a month
when I had these opportunities to make
you know 100k starting salary flying
around the world in the job I thought I
wanted to do and I didn't know was going
to work is easy to say now that I had I
worked out as a great i didn't know that
I was scared out of my mind I'm the
thing that just got me through with me
feeling like I can always get another
job and may not be with that company may
not look as good a minute there's many
benefits and all this stuff but I can't
I don't know if I'd ever get that
business opportunity again something in
here was like I gotta go and do it and
so making the big decisions in your life
with your heart and not your head and
then you use your head to figure out how
to make those decisions work yeah and I
think that's the last time you lost
stuff within the software industry but i
think is less than
all entrepreneurs can apply if there's
something that you want to do and that
you think you would read if you don't do
it then you owe it to yourself to try
even if it's scary if people think
you're crazy for doing it yeah and i
think you know uncertainty you're saying
and here's a couple of the most common
emotions that you get in the early
stages because you just don't know is
where is this going to go you might have
passion and purpose leave but you still
can't predict the future so you just we
just don't know which direction it's
going to take and then so you know
getting the that out of you the
uncertainty and fearlessness sort of
really turning out a certainty into
certainty or turning the fear to
fearlessness and all that sort of stuff
and I guess that's that's what reasons
what I would turn to your kind of
content you know what's that sort of
content I would enjoy it I'll be like
you know what you know it happen time
and time and time again Rivoli's I don't
see what the problem is where it
happening again this one time so I guess
one of the biggest values that we get
from your content I'm going to all that
other stuff have you been to us out of
the world yet I have not been to New
Zealand or to Australia i've been i've
been around asia a bunch of times for
speaking and stuff but I haven't been
there yet so it's on my list yeah we'll
have to see if we can see something up
to get thing I hear New Zealanders are
friendlier than Australians yeah we love
everybody I think so we gotta see I got
to put that too because I strands are
pretty friendly so so I'll have to put
it to the test and see I hope I'm by the
first Kiwi you met no no I met I met a
bunch of you know I met a bunch of
Zealanders and and I've seen the dance
the number of times and it's fine that's
fantastic oh look i mean everything i
think you know just going to stick to
the time I don't know if we still have
time or we know mark yeah so um you know
what what else can you sort of share I
guess with my community and with your
community in terms of what's coming
ahead for you you writing a book you're
mentioning as well yeah book comes out
december six it's about
self-awareness is about finding the one
word that defines you to help then you
make your your business and your life on
purpose instead of have I released it I
feel like I actually haven't released it
I feel like it actually releases this
weekend this Monday this is like bonus
we will see you guys watching this is
live bonus stuff because I just good I
should probably stop talking because I
publishes i canna back forget everything
you guys have heard because I haven't I
haven't I filmed it yesterday but I
haven't really it doesn't come out till
Monday games probably but so let's talk
about fear ah i chant something to say
about fear um I feel like people are
trying to avoid fear and and people tell
them or tell themselves don't be afraid
like I shouldn't be afraid right don't
be dear feelers be fearless we're really
for me it's more about feeling the fear
and doing it anyway it's not like expect
to be afraid it's okay to be afraid it's
normal to be afraid people are afraid
like oh I shouldn't be feeling this and
then they they bow down and they don't
actually take the action that they're
supposed to be taking aa people are
freaking on the comments about the book
uh so what I try to do when I'm afraid
is I try to step into it I try to do
things that make me uncomfortable on
purpose so an example that happened
recently was about socks this sounds
like something silly and stupid but I I
was moving I just moved to a new place
and when you move at least for me I had
all these socks like these single socks
that I was secretly hoping I was gonna
get the matching pair you know in the
wash but it never came so moving I gotta
throw away all these socks like I'm
never gonna find the matching pair
forget about it and I thought to my son
Hayden who's seven and he he insists on
wearing different colored socks all the
time you'll never wear matching socks
never uh and I thought why don't I just
wear different socks like who cares
what's the big deal and I had these
extra socks so you don't have to throw
them away and then my immediate thought
was oh what do people see me in these
different color socks what do people
going
to say how are people gonna judge me and
its like the fear of you know acceptance
from others yeah and as soon as I
recognize that fear instantly I had to
do it I had to do it like I don't want
to live my life based on what other
people will think of me so I have to get
used to pushing myself to do it and so I
wore different color socks that entire
day I went to a salsa thing at my
business at night and and I then made a
show of it and say hey I'm wearing two
different colored socks you know don't
worry about how people judge you go and
do something today um and so getting
used to doing those kinds of things
getting used to when you are afraid of
something going out and trying it
obviously within reason you know like
don't go jumping off a huge tower
without a parachute or something you
know like there are some things that you
may not need to conquer that fear but
most things are not actually things you
should be afraid of and by getting into
the habit of pushing yourself to when
you feel afraid of something to try it
on a small scale I find that that's
super helpful and a lot of times people
are are chewing you on I remember being
on a snowboard trail and I was on a ski
lift and I was going up a ski lift
there's this little girl like 10 years
old trying to these jumps on the
snowboarding hill and she would jump and
fall and jump and fall and jump and fall
I'm sitting doing that on the ski lift
thinking I hope she makes like if she
wanted to land one it sucks to fall down
every time and I'm at the top of the ski
ski line I look down and she's like lens
the last one to five min hill I'm so
happy for and I'm improving my
snowboarding skills and I get to the top
of the hill I'm ready to go down thing I
wonder if I can jump but what if I can
do that yeah and then instantly it's
like Oh what it like who's here who else
is on the hill who might see me fall I
don't want to fall and make it a fool of
myself with all these people watching
yeah and I thought back to like me look
at the girl on the chairlift and
thinking listen these people don't even
care and some of them will be cheer me
on to help me want to like to do it to
say yeah like hit that jump good job and
so we just automatically assume that
people are judging us and you know being
negative towards
Sin Cara but what we're doing and really
if you don't care about the opinions of
others I it just makes you stronger and
you get into the habit and practice of
being able to do that consistently so
I'm still afraid of a lot of stuff and
any time I recognize that I try to say
okay feel the fear and do it anyway well
anyway yeah and i think that's that's
part of the life journey because fear in
itself is learned behavior isn't it it's
um it's something you pick up as a child
because as a child you touch fire you
don't know it's fine you know you
realize afterwards that oppa should have
touched that that's exploring me or it's
hurting so that's that's that's feared
and self being learned as you grow but
um I think there's some natural things
like that I think there are like the hot
stove over some instinctive things I
think most of it those learned i think
most of it is is is taught from your
parents from your friends like if you're
afraid that you're not going to have
enough money it's because your parents
were afraid didn't or they didn't have
enough money a lot of it stems from from
learned behavior it's definitely makes
us not all learn but that allows you to
change it like if you can learn it then
you can unlearn it and it's just around
yourself with an environment where that
allows you to bring the best out in
yourself like if you're afraid of
failing being criticized as far because
you were criticized a lot when you were
younger and so now you're too afraid to
do anything because you were so critical
one of the reasons why I'm able to do
what i do is my parents always made me
believe like believe comes from them
they're on if you can see there that's
me when I was like six or seven those of
my parents they always told me that I
was like australie Carmichael and I can
do anything that I want my mom's last
name is cuz truly and so then dating
really criticized me for trying to do
stuff and that's allowed all three of us
who are two siblings two sisters to go
out in and chase unexpected things none
of us follow the traditional job path
when my parents were pretty traditional
with their career choices all three of
us went off and did different crazy
things and they supported us and made us
feel like we could do it and
other people don't have enough of that
in their lives whether it's parents or
the videos a watch or the interviews I
mean it's why your fan or chat series is
super important like listening to one of
your interviews might be the only shot
of inspiration that your listeners gets
in their life that's sad but it's also a
huge kind of responsibility for you two
to turn up and give them some quality
stuff and it's on every person watching
this too and listening in to don't just
accept the environment that you have
been given like so what if your parents
sucked so what if you're from you know a
country without a lot of resources like
you can either just complain for the
rest of your life that you weren't
gifted opportunities like other people
were or you can get up and make
something better change your environment
change people you hang out with consume
content that makes you better like you
need to create there's a reason why
these people are my wall right you need
to create a physical environment that
helps you push yourself to be that best
version of yourself and too many people
just accept the environment that was
given to them and that just holds them
where they are yeah i agree with that i
think you know that environment
sometimes becomes their excuse as well
without them achieve and realizing it's
like an inherent excuse but um what I'm
gonna just do a little segue because I
want to ask you the meeting toski you
know at one two or three entrepreneurs
right now that's on your radar who you
are either seeing seeing some amazing
success and inspiration that you're
sharing that content with others who are
more in the kind of last come up in the
last sort of five years who would you
sort of name you're looking at content
creators people creating stuff to look
out for like inspirational stuff to
watch I think just sort of entrepreneurs
who you've seen in the last five years
come up who you you know you share
stories with the likes of Walt Disney
and the likes of steve jobs and the real
them you know these guys have been
around you know decades but the guys
have been around maybe the last five
years who have done something equally
amazing who who who would you sort of
name drop their got it um
that's interesting I would I would look
I'm thinking people who like I've
learned stuff from and who would inspire
me a little bit i would go with gary
vaynerchuk a lot of you guys probably
already know him and if you're listening
to kind of motivation entrepreneur stuff
more for the content he creates as well
as the businesses building but a lot of
great content that you can learn from
and get inspired from and regular
content too I mean this my channel but
Gary does numbers of videos a week that
you can learn from and I like consuming
this stuff helps me um trying to be
careful like mega impactful um Kanye
West had a big impact on me and that's
within the last five years he's on the
wall there at the end a lot of people
hate on Kanye uh and he does do a lot of
crazy stuff that a lot of people can't
look past but the guy has won more
grammy awards at anybody for his eighth
in history he's successfully
transitioned multiple time to different
careers and the thing about ham that I
love is being unafraid to express
yourself like Kanye doesn't care yeah
well he'll go on say crazy stuff that I
may not agree with but he's not afraid
to do it where I think a lot of us are
too afraid to express ourselves but and
it's about doing it now you know that
that picture they are some a radio
interview that he did where he was going
on about you know I don't want to sit
inside a corporation for 20 years you
know the time is now the time is now to
be the greatest view the time was now to
express herself to go and claim what's
yours and so that's that like in urgency
and expressing yourself as things that
I've learned from him part of why I've
turned up to like watch a lot of his
stuff helps me turn up in not offending
people but to be the better version of
myself and the third person from the
past five years has had a big impact
what are you on the spot with this one
but i think you know it's that we've
just seen so much trajectory in
entrepreneur
in the last five years I think and
absolutely i mean this concept like the
easy answer is like elon musk ox or any
of these guys but it's not they hasn't
had like a massive impact on me where I
look at Elon I mean one thing I love I
love learning from different people to
make me the best version of me that's
the that's the that's the thesis of my
channel right is having all of these
famous successful people whether the
entrepreneurs are athletes are singers
or inventors or whatever and I can learn
something from this person to help me be
better you know you could learn
something from Donald Trump even if you
hate him you can learn something from
Hillary Clinton even if you hate her I
don't know who the new zealand
politicians and people are but like you
know somebody actually hate you can
learn from them to make you better so
Elon Musk one of the things I love what
Elon Musk besides like the thinking big
in the great visions and you know he
sees the world totally different that's
like the easy go-to thing one of the
things that blows me with Elon Musk is
he is not afraid to say he doesn't know
he was at he's on multiple interviews
and like we watch all this stuff and
pull together the best resources he was
on interview with CNN talking about how
artificial intelligence is the biggest
threat to mankind right and he's
creating he wants governments to donate
one percent of GDP to colonize Mars
because he's afraid we're gonna
self-destruct and it's a back-up plan
for Earth so that's thinking big right
like I want to make my city better this
guy is trying to have a back-up plan for
Earth but what so I mean that's the
thinking big but what what I loved about
it was she was asking him about like how
it would take place or you know where do
you see the rise of the robots happening
and he's like you know I don't know yeah
well x is like I don't know like would
you go on CNN and just say I don't know
it's a question that I just know the
answer to is the expert it it's just a
level of confidence and not caring about
how again he would be judged by the
media and the people watching it was
just super interesting to me helps me
kind of reflect on myself
and so I try to pull out those moments
from lots of different people yeah but I
don't think I don't think there's
anybody I don't know there's a third
person I'm probably missing somebody but
big impact on me over the past five
years I probably go with those two maybe
me the future founder chat series next
five years the founder Chad series could
have that level of impact who knows who
knows what the future holds we're gonna
see what we receive if we can turn the
uncertainty into some certainty there
but um you know it's funny you mentioned
Kanye West because i was reading the
other day that you had an idea to turn
his next album into a
software-as-a-service startup could
raise some funds through silicon valley
for that so that's that's kind of the
method of just thinking in a mad way to
reinvent the music industry so I the way
I sort of agree with you I think he does
think outside the box a lot with his
with his ideas and concepts so it's
pretty cool and most people can't
differentiate like you see a person and
unless they like like you don't like one
thing about them then I can't i'm not
i'm not paying attention to them they
can't pull out they can't ignore the
things that they hate to be able to pull
the things that they love like steve
jobs you know he's on the walls had a
big impact on me but he you know was not
a great manager of people like yelling
at people berating people hard to get
along with it's not something that I
personally agree with something I would
want to be as a leader in terms of
leading the team mmm but that's fine
like I don't want to be any of these
guys I want to be me I'll be the best
version of me and I can pull from
everybody here to do that and all the
people who are watching the videos and
so it just blows our mind that people
are so limited in where they can learn
from like if you have a guest on your
show who's super controversial or me and
me like maybe I'm saying something that
really bothers some but I pissed off the
Australians who are like I mean because
I said New Zealanders are nicer and now
they're like shut themselves off to
learning because I said one thing that
didn't agree with all right so people
see the world through that lens but the
australia new zones a bit like canada
USA go ah canadians have us envy in that
you know we compare ourselves to them
and we do a lot of trade with them and a
lot of our economy is tied to them
Americans don't pay attention to Canada
okay honest like it they don't care ah
it's it's like a state almost to them
they don't Americans have great
confidence in general and are very
insular where Canadians have to be more
global and think figure because our
economy can't support just ourselves and
so this yeah I don't know I don't know
what the relationship is new zealand
australia um there's not many things we
can peed on like maybe hockey canadians
love hockey the Americans are okay at
hockey so that's a big rivalry I guess
um that yeah it's very similar you know
New Zealand's were a population of very
four and a half million approximately so
you know we we have got a history of the
innovative and gold with a global
context in what we do exports a major
part of what what a country does so it's
you know we just kind of have to by
default we just kind of have to do that
you know otherwise we're just looking
after our own economy and for our people
so cool well I mean we're bumping up
against the clock for people who want to
learn more about you founder trance
series what's the best way to get in
touch I would I would love it if you
guys jump on to like i said earlier jump
if you are a mean academy and just put
in your name and email and click start
learning that'll get you onto our email
list or you can jump onto youtube type
and founder chats i'm pretty sure we're
optimize their or you can jump onto the
the apple store and type in firm academy
or founder chats and we've got an app
where we'll be posting these videos
regularly so that you can grab that
content right from your iphone and when
I start going to go live I would as soon
as I get a copy from you it's gonna go
alright well it goes live on YouTube
like 10 minutes or 30 minutes maybe
after after the session stuff Oh awesome
to meet you man thanks for the great
questions and waking up even though it
looks like it's two in the morning over
there thank you for sharing the great
questions thank you everybody for
watching still like tons of question
that we even get to but appreciate you
guys watching have an amazing evening
day continue to believe and we'll see
you soon thanks Evan see you in serato